identify which of the following numbers
are integers and then plot them on the
number line
so integers the best way to think of
them they're really the counting numbers
or the natural numbers plus 0
and the and the opposite of the counting
numbers so the counting numbers are like
1 2
3
4 so on and so forth if you add 0 to it
you then get the whole numbers and then
to that you want to add the negative
counting numbers or the opposite of the
natural numbers so
the opposite of 1 is negative 1. the
opposite of 2 is negative 2 the opposite
of 3 is negative 3 so on and so forth so
let's see which of these are integers 5
is definitely an integer
0.3 is not an integer it is not one of
these i guess you could call it
it is not either a a natural counting
number it is not 0 or is not the
negative of a natural counting number
negative 2 is an integer
negative 2 is an integer it's right over
here i actually wrote it down as an
example negative 1 3 is not an integer
for the same reason that 0.3 is it's not
one of these natural counting numbers
they're negatives or zero
negative 1.2 once again
once again it's not a whole number or a
negative natural number i guess is one
way to think about it
zero zero is included in the set of
integers so i'll stick that there 2
definitely is one of the things that i
drew as an example 9 7 is not it's
between it's between actual
integers and we'll plot it here on the
number line 4.1 not an integer once
again because it's not it doesn't evenly
or it doesn't land exactly on one of
either the natural numbers they're
negative or zero and then negative three
it is an integer i actually drew it here
as an example so let's plot all of these
so first i'll do 5 pretty straight
forward 5 is right over here
5 is right over here 0.3
0.3 so this is going to be a little bit
less than 1 3 so 0.3 is going to be
right over there so 0.3
then we have negative 2.
let me do negative 2 in blue negative 2
is 2 to the left of 0 right over there
actually already labeled it
negative two
one third
one third if you wrote it as a decimal
is zero point three three three three
three three so on and so forth so it's a
little bit bigger than zero point three
so i'll put it right over there it's a
little bit bigger that would be
one-third
and then negative 1.2
negative 1.2 i'll do it in this blue
color negative 1.2 well negative 1 takes
us there then we're going to have to go
another 0.2 or another one-fifth so
negative 1.2 will get us right over here
negative one point two
zero that's pretty straightforward zero
is right over there two once again not
too difficult two is two to the right of
zero
nine sevenths it's written as an
improper fraction and you might
recognize 7 goes into 9 one time and has
2 left over so 9 over 7
9 over 7 is the same thing 7 goes to 9
one time and has 2 left over so it's 1
and 2 7. so we go to 1 and then with 2 7
that's going to get us right about there
so 1 and 2 7 is going to be right about
there 4.1
4.1 is a little bit more than 4 so it'll
be right over there it's a 10th more
than four it's a tenth of the way to
five so four point one is right over
there and then finally we have negative
three that is just three to the left of
zero one two three we actually already
labeled it here negative three and we're
all done